[Music]
let's begin we invite you into our
circle if that's you give us a sign this
is a scam we do not attack the clients
we help people we give them closure at
all you are so weird she have a lot of
problems
that's nothing to concern what's this a
Ouija board for work spirit can you hear
me yes we can
who are you talking to what daddy huh
are you there for you
your sisters taking you to school today
I don't want to go I'm gonna stay here
and talk to my friends what friends I'll
show you
are you here something is happening that
we can't understand I'm concerned about
your girl what's this about father what
are you doing
the spirit world is dangerous they were
watching us all those years by using the
board you've opened up a portal want to
hear something cool sure you're not it
feels like to be strangled to death
first you feel the pressure in your
throat and you start to taste something
very sour in your mouth then it's like
someone lights a match right in the
middle your chest that fire grows it
fills your lungs and your throat and all
the way behind dries and the last thing
you feel is cold can i trow meow this is
a scam we do not attack the clients we
help people it gives them closure at all
is this a Ouija board